et nous sommes avec gérald ollivier
journaliste franco américain chercheurs
ali pse et jean-claude beaujour vice
président du cercle de réflexion
france-amérique bonsoir messieurs et
merci d'être avec nous ce soir
jean-claude beaujour c'est le jeu
classique de la diplomatie quelques mois
après l'arrivée au pouvoir de
l'administration d'haydn ou bien cette
visite d' anthony blinken et plus
déterminante que ça je crois tout
d'abord elle confirme la position qui
avait été celle du président américain
dans un premier temps rappelé que les
états unis sont un allié des occidentaux
votre reportage a indiqué que le
monsieur blink est née sur la même
philosophie que la la conception
européenne leadership américain le
président bak den l'avait rappelé
pendant sa campagne il voulait que
l'amérique reprennent le leadership et
là-dessus il n'y a pas de surprise au
fond anthony blinken fait le service
après vente
on est parfaitement d'accord là dessus
deux éléments me semble-t-il retiennent
droit de retenir notre attention
tout d'abord il est évident que
l'amérique soit ce front uni face à la
chine
et de ce point de vue je pense que c'est
cela que anthony blinken est en train
d'essayer de construire il faut donc une
riposte face à cette chine
et puis surtout d'une manière générale
il ya une forme de leadership
international que veulent reprendre les
états unis donc là dessus pas de
surprise en revanche pour moi une chose
qui est importante me semble-t-il c'est
que ça doit se faire ça se fera avec les
européens mais il pas simplement les
européens derrière les etats unis
et c'est là où il y aura probablement
des discussions parce que finalement et
on le voit bien les les intérêts globaux
sont les mêmes pour autant l'europe a
probablement un certain nombre
d'exigences à l'égard de la chine et
donc de ce point de vue il va il va
falloir un certain nombre de hauts
cadres âgés c'est dans le détail qu'on
verra si les politiques salies j'ajoute
qu'il y a une difficulté politique qui
ne nous échappera pas c'est que
l'allemagne et la france sont les deux
principaux pays européens dans le
entre de cette relation américano europe
vers le reste du monde et nous sommes
dans dans les deux cas dans les deux
pays en fin de mandat longue pour madame
merkel qui devrait quitter son poste à
la fin de l'automne prochain premier
élément est ce que le successeur de
madame merkel il rats dans dans le
prolongement de la politique de
l'actuelle chancelière
et puis d'autre part on est aussi malgré
tout en fin de mandat pour le président
pour le président mâcon donc là il ya
une petite incertitude politique
donc c'est pour moi le seul le principal
point d'achoppement
vous n'êtes pas d'achoppement mais
vraisemblablement de précision qu'il
faudra voir c'est dans le détail de la
politique qu'il faudra voir si nos
l'alliance atlantique états unis euros
vers le reste du monde se calme sur les
gros dossiers face à la chine mais aussi
vous l'avez rappelé en afghanistan pour
la légende en méditerranée et vers
l'afrique général ils disent que le
retour de l'amérique prenait 1 par joe
biden s'accordent avec la vision
française sur l'autonomie stratégique de
l'europe
sur le fond elle ne devrait pas la
vérité mais ce qu'on remarque c'est que
sur la forme
on est dans une véritable lune de miel
tout le monde est très content d'eux au
moins de l'atmosphère qui règne
désormais entre les états unis et
l'europe et tout le monde est content
des propos de joe biden joe biden a dit
à dire deux choses la première il a dit
america is back
alors à priori elle était apparemment
parti mais les relations étaient tendues
et il rajoute diplomatie isba et c'est
le retour de la diplomatie dont tout le
monde se félicite parce que c'est je
dirais pas le point fort mais c'est
c'est la carte principale que les
européens aiment jouer et donc on
profite actuellement de cette très belle
entente
mais comme le soulignait monsieur beau
jeu il ya quelques instants lorsque les
questions de fond vont revenir
eh bien on s'apercevra que les certaines
divergences vont revenir pour prendre un
exemple tout récent les européens et les
américains ont convenu de
pas poursuivre leurs guerres
commerciales autour des tarifs douaniers
sur l'acier et l'aluminium
mais je constate à moins d'avoir raté un
épisode qu'ils n'ont pas pour l'instant
éliminée
ces tarifs donc on est en train de
négocier pour trouver une sortie mais on
n'a pas convenu ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre de supprimer des tarifs qui
avait été mise en place par donald trump
et qui même s'il déplaise je dirais par
principe parce que c'est une je dirais
qu un obstacle au libre échangisme et
bien on s'aperçoit que à l'arrivée il
profite aux deux camps parce que
l'industrie de l'acier aux etats-unis
dans certains états comme la
pennsylvanie a pu se redresser et de ce
point de vue ces tarifs ont fait leur
effet et de l'autre côté les européens
ont pu taxer un certain nombre de
produits américains et et protéger leurs
propres produits en retour donc on a une
très bonne atmosphère pour l'instant
mais lorsque l'on examinera les dossiers
de fond on verra sur quoi cette
atmosphère débouche j'entraîne beaux
jours vous évoquiez tout à l'heure le
couple franco allemand mercredi à
anthony blinken était à berlin
et il a eu cette phrase il a déclaré que
les états unis n'avaient pas de meilleur
ami que l'allemagne est ce que cela
signifie que les relations diplomatiques
avec la france passe au second plan
non non je ne pense pas parce que vous
savez que en allemagne mais nous avons
un certain nombre de voix se sont
élevées pour pouvoir ici ou là sinon
critiquer mais rappelé qu'il y avait des
intérêts allemands qui parfois devrait
devait primer sur le reste de la
politique européenne parce que
finalement nous sommes 27 et que les
vingt-sept
nous avons des rapports avec les états
unis nous avons des rapports et et c'est
vrai que ça vient d'être d'être rappelé
par monsieur ollier
nous avons des rapports qui par la suite
doivent être regarder secteur par
secteur
or l'allemagne à un secteur industriel
très fort c'est sa préoccupation et nous
savons très bien qu'il y a certains
nombre de points de divergence les etats
unis ont eu beau
elle rappelé aux allemands ben qu'ils
avaient été enfin en tout cas à défaut
d'avoir intérêt mais que la nouvelle
relation la nouvelle construction ne se
ferait pas sans sens sans elle j'ajoute
que le président biden avait a déjà
rappelé aux alliés lorsque lors de son
passage qu'il y à vaste plan
d'infrastructure pour rivaliser avec les
nouvelles nouvelles routes delà de la
route de la soie chinoise et donc c'est
une façon de dire aux européens et en
particulier aux gros états industriels
je vise la halle allemagne que ben les
allemands entre l'intérêt commercial à
être géré vite hier à être dans cette
démarche qui est cette politique voulue
par le par le président par le président
wade est donc je crois que la
connaissance comme le sublime qu'elle a
aussi l'europe c'est un europhile
francophile il connaît très bien le
tissu européen il sait très bien qu'il
ne suffit pas d'avoir une politique
globale mais qu'après une fois les
convaincre et à parit à l'allemagne vous
l'avez rappelé la france aujourd'hui et
puis après il ya l'italie qui sont en
quelque sorte les trois moteurs de
l'europe vous souvenez que les chinois
réessayer ou tente en tout état de cause
d'expliquer aux italiens qu'ils ont
intérêt à avoir une politique de
proximité avec entre l'italie et la
chine donc on voit bien qu'il ya une
volonté réflexion globale d'un côté et
puis après pays par pays il faut
convaincre parce que monsieur dean cain
sait bien qu'en europe il ne suffit pas
de dire nous ferons telle chose que
l'europe va dans tel sens mais qu'après
il faut aller convaincre les principaux
états de du bienfait de la politique
menée par par joe biden parce que une
fragmentation de l'europe sur cette
relation et sur ce sujet-là serait
risque d'échec pour la politique
américaine
alors on vante la francophonie la
francophilie d' anthony blinken gérald
olivier est ce que ça peut avoir
quelques conséquences est ce que ça peut
avoir sur les relations franco américain
a écouté ça fait très plaisir à la
france que le secrétaire d'état
américain
français je me suis blinken de ce point
de vue là est le plus francophone de
tous les secrétaires d'état même encore
mieux que notre ami john kerry qui
s'exprimait parle parfois en français
lors des conférences de presse au quai
d'orsay
mais de manière assez vrai cela dit et
pour enchaîner sur ce qu'a dit monsieur
beaux jours concernant le fait que
monsieur blink n est passé par
l'allemagne d'abord et qu'il sera demain
en italie
rappelons que l'allemagne sur le plan
économique pèse un petit peu plus lourd
que la france aujourd'hui
et puis le grand enjeu pour les états
unis dans leurs relations avec l'europe
et en particulier avec l'allemagne c'est
le fameux projet north stream de donner
aux ducs et de gazoduc entre direct sous
marin entre entre la russie et
l'allemagne et que les états unis même
si il aura directement donné leur feu
vert puisque donald trump avait imposé
des sanctions à toutes les entreprises
impliquées dans ce projet et que ces
sanctions ont été levées par joe biden
l'intérêt jdir et stratégique des
américains aujourd'hui il est beaucoup
plus pressant vis-à-vis de l'allemagne
qu'il ne l'ait vis-à-vis de la france de
ce point de vue là la france et les
états unis
sentant que je dirais relativement bien
je rappelle que sur le plan commercial
la france est un excellent partenaire
des états unis et les états unis sont un
excellent partenaire pour la france
c'est un des rares pays avec lequel nous
avons une balance commerciale
excédentaire et que sur le plan je dire
de la stratégie les français des
américains s'entendent très bien parce
que le sur le plan militaire la france
est le pays d'europe le plus avancé le
plus développé et le plus impliqué sur
un théâtre qui indirectement intéresse
les américains qui le théâtre africain
notamment le théâtre sahéliens et la
coopération dans le cadre de l'opération
barkan s'est relativement bien passé
donc de ce point de vue là les états
unis et la france ont tout intérêt à
s'entendre d'ailleurs c'est pour moi le
sens du communiqué vis-à-vis du liban
même si là
on a beaucoup plus je dirais des bons
sentiments qu'une véritable politique et
la capacité d'imposer un changement
il n'empêche que sur le plan des
questions stratégiques curé sur le plan
commercial
au delà de la francophilie des uns ou
des autres
il ya de très bonnes raisons pour que
les etats-unis et la france entendent
bien aujourd'hui tout d'arriver assez
rapidement avec vous jean claude
beaujour on l'a vu en cet accueil très
chaleureux de jean yves le drian ce
matin lorsqu'il a retrouvé son ami
anthony blinken les deux hommes se
connaissent très bien sur quels dossiers
internationaux chaussettes bonne entente
peut-elle permettre peut-être de changer
la donne et trouver des compromis
je pense que vous commandiez comme suivi
viens de dire sur le sahel c'est un
sujet qui est un sujet brûlant pour nous
c'est un sujet brûlant parce qu'il y a
urgence à ce qu'il y ait une certaine
stabilité dans cette partie de l'afrique
on voit bien que la france est un peu
tout seul sur cette région et qu'il
aurait besoin d'un effort particulier
des américains en tout cas que l'on
puisse agir de d'un commun accord et de
concerts sur cette région
on sait que anthony blinken avait été
très critique à l'égard de dépositions
de donald trump non seulement sur cette
partie de l'afrique mais aussi sur la
syrie et c'est donc de ce point de vue
nous avons intérêt à ce que dans
méditerranée et dans dans celle qu'il y
ait une avancée significative les
américains on sait sont assez sensibles
à la démarche que nous nous entreprenons
est donc là dessus peut y avoir un
consensus en tout cas une démarche qui
satisfasse les autorités les autorités
françaises merci à vous bonjour je
rappelle que vous êtes vice président du
cercle de réflexion france-amérique
merci gérald ollivier journaliste
franco-américaine chercheur à l'ehess
merci messieurs d'avoir participé à ce
débat ce soir sur arte france